Mon rêve est de transformer Jérusalem en bière
de cannabis en vrac en Israël où l'on trouve également
Industrie, technologie et recherche
[musique]
et développement
Au début, il y avait des gens qui haussaient un sourcil
Principalement parce qu'ils avaient un passé d'utilisation difficile
dans la drogue et j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à leur apprendre
les effets positifs que cette plante produit
produire dans la vie de
[musique]
Les gens mais non, pas dans ce modèle, ce modèle est
L'un des premiers au monde et son métier est de rassembler tout le monde
qui a déjà eu une idée pour améliorer les processus
Dans le monde du cannabis, toute la recherche et le développement de
Les produits seront là en leur présence
[musique]
h